good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday I feel
like this is the most earned Thursday in
a really long time like I earn this
[ __ ] I agree and I hate to be like one
of those people in one of those shows
that like talk about the days of the
week so much ice which by the way it's
all we do this week it's all we do this
week because every time you say good
morning Millennials it's blings like I'm
so fearful you're gonna get it wrong oh
by the way because I get everything
started because on Monday you said it
was a Friday and just call me Color Me
hopeful okay yes I understand it is a
beautiful Thursday here in New York and
it's a coincidental Thursday because
Jackie and I showed up in the same shirt
I can't believe actually this hasn't
happened more just given the fact that
pretty much I only live in my own merch
I only live in tow Smurfs this is the
Old English shirt I'm wearing it in
black jack is wearing it in white the
white is a new color that we just
launched is available at morning to a
sec I actually like my white better but
it's laundry day and the back has the
toast on it oh yeah just don't mind us
in our day little QVC moment it's Old
English toast in the back black anyway
you can wear it as a dress Jackie's
wearing a large as a dress sadly I'm
wearing a large as a shirt because
that's just the way life works no this
is really my favorite outfit to wear
like some variation of toast merge boots
it's the easiest thing the world today
if you're on a headband and all of a
sudden I have a brand new look no by the
way can you just take back what you said
about headbands
yes oh my god okay meet Jackie and Margo
we're in LA we're all in our hotel room
and Jack is just like going off on about
how girls who wear headbands have no
style not I didn't say girls who have
headbands I said girls who wear that
headband oh the one with the knot at the
top I was just like I said something
really mean and I'm gonna take it back
okay thank you oh my god back because I
wore had been twice this weekend I
thought I looked so keep updated I love
it when my hair isn't done I like when
you wear it with him button because you
just look like a bet and I jump some
she's true Thomson I think it's a sweet
look on you um thank you so much I'm so
glad that you could offer a retraction
for your offensive statement but I
didn't make the statement on the show so
no one knows that I had said it no but
it's like you rolled in today wearing a
headband looking super cute I'm like oh
the nerve but also I said it about that
had been that's not at the top I just
want to say not about these thick
headbands but I really have to thank the
snatcher because she got me a really
nice headband for my birthday I would've
started me on the
headband kick so Thank You snatchler for
proving me wrong also Thank You
snatchler for uploading today's episode
of the snatchler and being so vulnerable
yes Margo and you know what I was there
for the the moment where Margo like how
to break down at the t PG Awards but I
didn't really know the full extent of it
like I said anyone realize that she left
super early and alone because of this
whole thing so she talks all about it
she got so much hate I was a knight I
was out for the breaking point and like
she kind of took it out on me she left
me in the bathroom alone and like she
was just walking out of me as my
casually someone's taught her
syncopation so I had time to catch up to
her um but listen because you know what
it's like you think the snaps are so
strong she's a girl who has it all going
on and most of the time she is but like
and she calls them keyboard warriors you
and you probably don't think that it's
that it's you who's doing it but like
anyone who message just listen to the
episode yeah honestly she made a really
good point about how she knew people
were making fun of her outfit because
her Instagram story had more shares than
usual so it's like while people might
not even be directly messaging her that
they thought her outfit was ugly they
were sending it to their friends which
is honestly worse right and sometimes
you get a lot of shares but you also get
a lot of replies which means everyone's
just buzzing about me right positively
but when it's just shares no reply yeah
I never thought of that now I'm gonna be
like so aware of my shares I never
looked at my shares I don't even know
that was a thing until Margo just
pointed out on the episode so now I'm
gonna be like so aware of it and when
she was having her breakdown she called
me from the bathtub hysterically crying
when I was like leaving the TPG award
she was in the bathtub and I was just
like homegirl we have been through worse
like I know and it's just you know what
it's it's easier to listen like when
someone's saying like and Margo know
knew it knew it was like minutia but
like when you're in your feelings your
inner feelings yeah and once you're in
them and you've already like broken the
seal of crying you just have to write
out the cry you can't just stop mid cry
doesn't just go away you just have to
cry through the night go to sleep wake
up a brand new woman and that's what
she's doing and she's telling you about
it on the Snatcher so I thought it was a
very brief episode for considering like
she's been a podcaster for a few months
now and she's already being so open and
vulnerable with her audience she's a
true influencer she's at her core we're
gonna recap Real Housewives of New
Jersey and Dallas both of which were
amazing episodes that I have a lot of
thoughts on so we will be doing that at
the end of the episode so many thoughts
so many thoughts it's actually not fair
Dallas and New Jersey are on the scene
oh great because it's too much premium
content I'd rather them on separate
nights or group one of them with OSI
like know also Monday nights are open
right now on Bravo like a low deck so
it's not so Monday nights are open on
Bravo and I just say nights are open yet
Thursdays like not a Housewives night
like Bravo is Sunday through Wednesday I
don't know I was just like very
overwhelmed because I have so many
opinions both seasons are incredible and
I can't wait to talk about meet you I
have a lot of thoughts so we'll get into
that at the end of the episode but
before that we got a we got to do our
job and my delivery man because we're
delivering we're about to deliver today
the Fast Five story is that you need to
know yes you before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast great
oh yeah yeah no for sure it's definitely
time like I don't want to uh we need to
come up with a better transition like
I'm over like you're being arty I'm over
being RTA I'm learning it oh that's fine
yeah I thought you were just like it was
just getting popular let's do what other
podcasters do I just want to say when I
do toast membership a lot of people have
been saying recently another favor
toasty inside joke is already aged oh
right that they would be RDH if they
tell maybe I won't do it every day maybe
I'll do it other podcasters do and just
stop in the middle of today's episode is
brought to you by love book they help
customers express the sentiments that
may be difficult to say out loud each
book is completely customizable but most
customers use them to list the reasons
why they love someone users can create
characters that look just like
themselves and the recipient down to the
outfits and accessories while customers
have the option to personalize each page
as much as they like our express wizard
option creates a complete book with just
a few look with just a few options so
basically love book is such a cute idea
actually for a gift it's holiday season
if you can't think of what to get
someone and materialistic things just
like aren't gonna cut it like these days
like I've gotten been pretty much like
every ermes belt there is out there like
honestly something more sentimental is
that what it requires love book is such
a cute idea too totally customizable
book where you can like create a story
and the characters look just like you
would been like how cute is that
basically like it's what Kim Kardashian
did for Kim Kardashian Hollywood like in
a book you know so cute honestly Zach
would love that yeah okay and he doesn't
watch his show so I could get it for him
and it could still be a surprise it is
the perfect gift for all occasions like
Christmas Valentine's Day anniversaries
and birthdays it's not just for you it's
always a gift it is ideal that's special
for that special someone that's really
deserving of a meaningful present um if
you want to check it out learn more
about it maybe get someone for someone
someone
in your life visit love book online.com
slash toast to receive a special 20%
discount today only for our listeners
so that's loves book online.com slash
toe still got a special 20% discount
just for you guys to check it out great
idea for a gift great idea in the middle
of their sentences great idea
well like that transition mm-hmm saina
oh now I see what you did there thank
you
sign on be a good gift giver because
people really respect the hell out of
and because there aren't enough of us in
the world there just aren't okay you
ready for our first story
okay now I'm looking at myself in the
YouTube and in my gym this headband it's
like a little silly just from the side
like it's so big you know any nice
little thick - yeah well just a couple
of thick girls totally okay first story
crazy stuff we report on the toast
Instagram yesterday that our Kelly
surviving our Kelly part 2 is coming to
life time in January it's called the
reckoning so it's obviously gonna be
about the past year in light of the part
one of the documentary it's confusing
though because when I heard it was
called the reckoning I thought it was
going to be The Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills reunion where Lisa
Vanderpump shows up yeah that that is
confusing and I saw a lot of tweets
where people were like oh what huh yeah
um but no it's just this is better but
it's confusing but it is confusing
well the reckoning of our Kelly is so
confusing because I'm not sure if it's
happening you're not been fully reckoned
because Joycelyn like came on Instagram
like said she was like free and that she
was gonna talk and she was like back
with her family then it turned out sound
patreon oh my god then it turned out
that was totally fake
why yeah and like someone was pretending
to be Joycelyn teen to get the patreon
money and then it's like it was real it
wasn't it's like there's no way of
knowing if Joycelyn is like actually
free oh my god they need the reckoning I
was actually thinking like I must have
been while we were away because we
didn't report on it but now I'm glad we
didn't because it was fake news
potentially and it just goes to show you
that if you're gonna make a patreon you
go to patreon.com/scishow morning coats
totally we're the only ones doing it
right um well big news is that our
Kelly's ex-wife wants nothing to do with
surviving our Kelly is that the wife who
was in the first riot Kelly yeah who
they have a bunch of kids together she
was like the main raise right is how
she's a dancer and it's cute - yes she
was not pleased with the way that
lifetime handled some of the first
season no so she will not be
participating she believes lifetime
purposefully included a clip from her
segment in the first documentary in
order to promote this
which she now wants to distance herself
from the mother of three reportedly had
many grievances with the network
regarding the initial documentary saying
executives ignored her request by
reaching out to her children and family
members about part two
oh she also feels lifetime failed to
properly care and provide support for
the victims who have already come
forward who quote she has no involvement
did not approve any footage or stills of
her likeness and is not actively
promoting nor consulting the follow-up
series I understand why she doesn't want
a really need to be in the follow-up
series like series number one got the
job done and she was an integral part of
it so I don't think her not being a part
of the second one has anything to do
with like the way she feels about our
Kelly like she's like forgiving him or
something
I just think it's like enough like
eventually you do have to move on with
your life and like he's no longer her
husband and she's gotta move on right
she said her piece at the end of the day
he is still the father of her children
so she said what he needed to do but now
this second part I look forward I'll
watch the entire thing and I hope
there's you know it sheds light on the
sack that it's not so easy to cancel
someone who's so clearly a monster right
um but the story has been been told and
I feel like the steps are being taken
now it's at this point it's just like a
cash grab like I thirst it was a story
that needed to be told now it's like
let's get viewers and ratings yeah I
just they're trying to continue to ride
the magic yeah and I'm not against it
and I look forward to seeing it and then
I will make my judgment on whether or
not it was necessary yeah I think it's
definitely not necessary but I'm still
like living for it I love just content
to consume so I'll survive totally okay
you ready for tonight that was a great
series oh my god it was so great I know
that I'm a lifetime like subscriber I
pay through the nose for doing movie
club and I just have every lifetime app
like I have the works yeah I'm over we
go back to Denis chief I don't know I
kind of gave up on life time when I was
in Canada and the only thing to watch
was live time and they made me watch
this terrible Christmas movie with Mayim
Bialik who like has made a career off of
being a modest Jewish woman which is why
we stand but like what are you doing in
a Christmas movie granted she did play a
half Jewish character who was half
celebrating Christmas she was like the
Christmas cynic she was like the Grinch
it was just like such a poorly done
movie and like she was in the airport
after leaving the a bed-and-breakfast it
was just like it was so wannabe Hallmark
and it was just like so poorly done and
like I I need my mind be out like in a
lot of places like I don't need her in a
lifetime Christmas I understand and it
just hurts me
that's you've been your experience I
think you should come over for a day of
Christmas movie watching at my place but
like I can barely do I can barely get
through a Hallmark Christmas movie and I
feel like I was really into them like a
few years ago when we all started
watching them and like you and Margo
like became so obsessed them that like
now I like hate it and then in in Utah
we were watching and it's like oh now I
remember why I hate it like I can't
suspend disbelief like that much that
hard living in this fake fantasy world
were like nobody has any real
responsibilities and like if you care
about your job you're suddenly a bad
person like I just I have a lot of
problems with like the the ethics of
Hallmark's movies here's the thing I
respect your opinion um but I must let
you know that what you are saying is
very triggering to me no I know um an
offensive okay and I kind of like what
you said about my headband right and
they just need like a safe space right
yeah no and by the way change my mind
you know I'm open to it it's just like
that one movie that we watching I don't
need like I I respect like I can see how
you could say that yeah and like on it
the beauty and like the hallmark II and
the Christmas and the lights like I love
that but it's like the idiots in the
movie like I just can't I can't get on
board I prefer to watch geniuses like
Mayim Bialik well speaking of disgusting
man Harvey Weinstein reaches a tentative
25 million dollar deal to settle I'm
sorry claims this is not even the most
important like that should not be the
headline Harvey one seed leaves court
with a walker
did you see a seed with tennis balls
yeah oh my god it's so weird he looks
like he doesn't need a walker it's like
such a prop but you know what I mean or
the tennis ball has this commitment
it's very but makes it very believable
but it was just like such a weird flex
like I saw the story and I was like damn
let me look at this video and I love
watching people like walk in and out of
court houses because like they don't get
escorted out the back like you have to
live with the shame of paparazzi like
that to me is one of the like it's just
as bad as going to prison like this
shame of having to walk from the curb to
your car it's like it's too much so I
wanted to watch and I'm like homeboy is
in a roller wheelchair marker and I'm
like what the [ __ ] it's been like a year
what has happened in a year I don't know
I don't know he looks awful truly awful
dozens of alleged victims who sued
former movie producer Harvey Weinstein
sorry I'm just I'm feeling I'm feeling
empowered by the today's episode of the
snapshot and I need to call someone out
your name is Kelsey done
love Claude but I don't like the
headband lobe on luck okay you're
entitled to your opinion like was it
absolutely necessary that you comment
that like I think your life would go on
just as well I'm just a sign if you
didn't leave that comment like I'm gonna
start calling [ __ ] out like sorry
that was rude I don't give a [ __ ] if you
don't like it honestly I'm looking in
the mirror and I don't like it either
Duty makes me feel good to see that
Kelsey Tom doesn't like it either keep
your [ __ ] opinions to yourself
picture don't comment on my [ __ ]
YouTube stream sorry dr. Harvey
Weinstein you got that off their chest
the disgraced Hollywood mogul and the
bored of who's bankrupt film studio have
reached a ten minute twenty five million
dollar agreement to settle multiple
claims according to attorney Steve
Berman who represents some of the
victims if approved by a judge the
settlement would not require Weinstein
to either in mid-to-long doing or pay
anything personally the money would be
part of an overall forty seven million
dollar deal which would settle Weinstein
obligations and those of his former film
production company including his brother
Robert Weinstein but isn't he broke well
actually the film liked the company and
the insurance policy would pay out this
money oh we actually wouldn't pay well
good I'm glad that everyone's getting
their yeah and this isn't I'm preaching
like the lawsuit is separate from the
the legal charges against him right he's
still on trial these are for civil suits
uh-huh and I'm pretty sure I read in
this host centers which is where I get
all my facts that these are for cases
that were beyond the statute of
limitation but you could still sue a
[ __ ] yeah cool cool cool I don't
have to pay that and I think he will
still be on trial for the charges that
were right that are still right in the
last like ten years or whatever already
so crazy I just feel like the rise and
fall of Harvey Weinstein is hysterical
like living for it you know yeah and I
love seeing like him like randomly
popping up places like he went to a bar
in Arizona and like got the [ __ ] beat
out of him like he just keeps showing up
in places someone slapped him and then
he went to that comedian thing yeah look
why do you I don't know why why does he
I don't know if his Arizona it was like
some desert you know and I said why do
you keep showing up places like stay in
your house maybe nice house you're not
allowed like to be a person anymore like
you should move but you have a civil
suit that'll he can't leave the country
yeah you know he should just stay home
he should be on house arrest like self
uh
self-inflicted house arrest thank you
also um actually don't know if he could
really travel with his name Walker so
maybe that's why but also okay so he was
at that
that comedian thing what three months
ago we were talking about that on the
toast so now he needs a walker he's
another Walker at the comedian thing but
he was just sitting you wouldn't know if
he had a walker he he'd look like he had
a walker it's not like he got up and
walked around but I just feel like
they're like if everyone seen on a
walker like I would have known about it
do you know I mean I don't know when I
you do right and you don't really see
him that often he's always just sitting
being straightly escorted to a table
also those court walks are very long so
maybe yes he can walk from the cab to
the curb but he can't walk up those
steps through the judicial you know go
down to row 304 did you also see cardi B
showing up to the court case snatchler
yeah as the snatcher with a train and a
hat and sunglasses and a bodyguard she
looked so chic and while I don't believe
in like the glamorization of you know
petty crime I do think she looks
glamorous right and like you said
everyone has to do that walking so it
might as well make it work to your
benefit totally she's in the courthouse
on vogue in the strip club and it's
still been less than a week you guys
let's see what else she can do um people
in the comments are saying allegedly he
was in a car accident
Harvey Weinstein yeah wouldn't that be
news yeah I know I didn't hear about
that also you know what's so crazy is
that like Kevin Hart is still like
recovering from his car accident he came
out recently said he's only like 60% 70%
of the way there is that crazy that's
crazy I'm praying for him I love him
come back soon Kevin come back soon
Kevin heart rate you could stay inside
your house we don't need you agreed fun
story
you can now buy Megan Markel's actual
briefcase from Deal or No Deal
I heard him don't be cheap you may not
be able to buy the Royal jewels but you
can buy something from one something
special from one Royals life years
before Megan Marco became the Duchess of
Sussex
she was a briefcase model on the NBC
game show series dealers they'll call
them a briefcase model yes she was
modeling briefcases and now her fans
have a chance to purchase her briefcase
for themselves the number 24 briefcase
that Marco held on the series from 2006
to 2007 is officially up for auction via
profiles in history's Hollywood
collector and some auction that's crazy
the prop is listed at number 7 83 on the
auction list and is expected to be sold
for between 4,000 and 6,000 dollars I
make a great call as to who's going to
buy
chrissy teigen like she can she's
obsessed with Meagan Martin I think
sassy shoulders and I know honestly yeah
anything when she shadow he's not that
much like first celebrity no we and not
for a piece of history should the toast
chime and buy it let's get let's go it
to the auction and I wouldn't use it as
a briefcase like for all my important
work okay but if we're writing it
together like you're using at a
three-point I'll carry your stuff you
okay actually I'm okay with thank you
could carry the briefcase sometimes
notes okay you can area and will just
show up everywhere
throw the briefcase on the table open it
how much money was in I guess it was
different for every episode right wow
this is such an exciting time I didn't
know that like you could just like
auction like who owns this right now
currently like the network I feel as
though it would be NBC or like the
production company that produces well
that's what's gonna he brought his own
briefcases to issue who I obey BYOB I
told you I've been recently watching I'm
watching so much em MSN no CNBC which is
the channel that plays Shark Tank reruns
American greed reruns and now do you
learn oh do we even watching any
American green know it's not my vibe I'm
not into like a serious documentary I
love a game show
so Shark Tank to me is like a game show
and then Deal or No Deal comes on after
I'm like I just have to watch it's such
an interesting concept for a show and
it's really such a great game show that
has withstood the test of time you know
what I mean yeah what was it it was 30
rock when they did like a play on Deal
or No Deal and what's called a gold bar
and the game was like you know but all
these cases were so heavy and you know
if it had gold in it or not really rock
with such an amazing show every few
years I feel compelled to rewatch it and
I'm feeling like the urge again it's
such a good show I don't even like if
you were to ask me who my favorite
character is like I literally couldn't
pick between Tracy or Jenna or Jack
Donaghy 100% Kevin Purcell it definitely
is not Liz Lemon but I feel like you're
not mental like was Lemon you're not um
[ __ ] did you see the new trailer for a
curb no the new season is coming out
they just really surreal ur and it looks
I mean it looks just like urban I'm so
excited
are they releasing it weekly I don't
remember cuz I watched yeah it's just
like a regular show it's not a geomatics
like no because they've only watch
terrific show for weeks really I've only
watched curb in both because I watched
it after like it's time on air and it's
just one of those shows I'd like to like
watch a bunch of episode so I don't know
if I'll watch week to week maybe I'll
just watch
yeah I might do that too but I'm just
excited that it's back me too
what a crazy time that like curve is
back do you know what I mean mm-hmm I've
been watching friends on Netflix and
there's like a little I know little text
that comes up every time you start an
episode that said this title is only
available till January first what the
[ __ ] I have to buy it on Amazon Prime
Geoffrey what the [ __ ] it's only $60 for
the whole thing that's like a lot of
money to spend on television but I guess
it's like eight seasons I just feel like
if I don't buy it now but you should
100% buy it and then the parts that were
cut out you'll you I know that is such a
good investment for you and for Theo and
his anxiety your anxiety 100 out there
for you for Hanukkah okay well I'm so
glad I brought it up Happy Hanukkah
oh by the way um we know how we were
talking at the Masterclass yes well
people were talking about it in the
toasters how it's an amazing gift oh and
they don't want to spoil anything but
Zach doesn't watch the show oh it's not
for Zach but anyways I signed up for the
master class you did for you because
they have this new promotion going on
buy one gift one whether this is not
enough no buy one gift one free so like
oh I'm so I don't want to say anything
else cuz it's it's a surprise this is
the rent no no yeah I'll tell you after
oh but it's like I'm not hiding
information when do you choose one
person okay so you have to make an
account and then you can give someone
one class or with but with this
promotion you can give to them a year of
unlimited classes Wow and now I also
have unlimited classes so I'm gonna do
Bob iger's and I'm gonna do Sara Blakely
oh we've gotta have like a viewing party
Bob iger's Judd Apatow has one company
oh there's not one on podcasting which I
think they should get Joe Rogan to do
one unpack what a thousand for some and
not Conan O'Brien even though I've been
hearing actually really good things
about his show
Conan's podcast yeah I've actually been
hearing amazing things about Oliver and
Kate Hudson's how that went that's not
surprising you know they have great
social media and they they film some
clips and I was just like watching clips
on their Instagram their Instagram
already at 75,000 followers it's like I
usually hate when celebrities come into
the podcasting space but I'm really
excited about it and like obviously we
need to get on because it's a podcast
about siblings oh that's a good goal you
know just like yeah let me add that's my
list of goals that we were discussing
yesterday yes please do I love having
goals um anyways so that was just
interesting and I feel like
it's a great gift idea for people so I
just wanted to share that factoid that I
learned about obviously in the toasters
group ok added like Gordon Ramsay
teaches a cooking class yeah I heard I
saw comments on the toaster scream about
someone who did that I just don't know
how to cook or like to cook so Martin
Scorsese teaches filmmaking
oh great how to make a three hour movie
that nobody likes how to make shutter
island' no and yeah oh you know what I
did yesterday I just wanted a way to
segue into so we were talking about our
end of decade playlist yeah and I'd had
my biggest artist for the decade but I
didn't have my biggest songs and my top
five artists and I just wanted to be so
interest okay so I'd like to share with
the class please share with the class
okay cuz everyone knows my number one
artist of the decade was Little Mix
which makes sense number two Kelly
Clarkson makes more sense number three
Rascal Flatts makes a lot of sense
number four One Direction makes a lot of
sense number five Ariana Grande
well consistent makes so much sense I've
been listening to every morning to my
2019 rapt playlist and I'm just like
damn I have such good taste in music oh
it's so fun except does anyone have like
a robe song in there like that you've
never heard there is a random Frank
Sinatra song in my rap to playlist and I
don't share an account with anyone like
it's so weird
that's so weird I'm sure you can delete
it it's just a fluke for sure there's no
way it's data no I know but it's so
weird do you want to hear something more
interesting that I found to be so
interesting my top songs of the decade
okay
this song that I listened to most in the
last ten years I'm never gonna guess
okay what is a fight song well you're
such a loser
number two love me like you do I love
that you do love that song number three
steal my girl everybody wanna steal my
girl but you can't have her cuz she's a
total [ __ ] remember that vine fine
modestly I've been like alive in the age
of chick talk these days but it's really
bring me back to those days when I used
to just like scroll like people were
just so funny and creative and now
certain things member I said John Mayer
dot-com like things just stick with you
and music I can't listen to steal my
girl without being like but you can
never cuz she's a total [ __ ] that's so
funny I'm loving tick-tock and I'm so
here for a nice girl with no job Jackie
oh and I think it's just great like the
tick tock is making me excited to have
children because I think it's a great
creative outlet for children and by the
way
I've been seeing like a lot of the posts
echovirus on my fur you page it's just
like it's such an eclectic different
group of people it's like it's for
everyone do you hear everyone and it
just makes me a little sad because
growing up like I would have loved to
talk all we did growing up with make up
dances yeah like copy dances that we saw
on TV like we would have been tick tock
queen no we would have been like
literally Queens right now in my life I
don't have the time to make up a dance
and I also don't have the time to like
learn a dance from a video so I'm like
too self-aware now to realize like I'm
not that good of a dancer you know it's
like when I was a kid I thought I was
like a [ __ ] Beyonce and now it's like
I feel myself dancing yesterday I was
like oh my god I'm a terrible dancer is
this what I look like in the club No
yeah okay no I mean club is like I could
fist pump with the best of them but I
can't just be like look that's just not
me you know no in the club I like I need
a couple square feet to myself yeah of
course self-expression yeah I'm in a
music I've been to a club in a long time
I was actually thinking I'm getting um
like a group chat started by me having a
Gianna on Saturday oh you know what I
actually had um a month like yes I'm in
oh you're in it I would start a group
chat because I think Danny's in town oh
no oh yeah oh wow um I miss like the
episode of Friends where they have a
friend you know what I can't remember
his name which is so weird cuz I know
everything I think this thing is
whatever I'd like there this one friend
it's like when he comes to town it's
like it's like in the air and that's
Danny totally oh my gosh I'm so excited
she had oh I just she was excited like
four week for the weekend but it doesn't
look like the weekend because have to
work Friday night turning chefs you know
takes a while Carlton job calm like I
actually so I get are saying I don't
want to spoil your show for anyone okay
I just want to give them a taste of what
they can expect okay stones being turned
yeah for sure so I get um I get emails
every day with like updated ticket
counts for all my shows and it's like
it's a big chart and I was looking
yesterday I never really look at them
cuz I cube it to sell a my shows out
like I don't really need to sell tickets
that's a lot of guys so much um and it's
a chart and like it usually goes on for
like I scroll literally my chart is so
little now cuz I only have 7 shows left
you guys are you gonna be ok no I think
you're gonna go through with Charl I
know I'll figure it out it's anyone
interested in hearing the rest of my top
songs in the decade honestly now really
I love you and I'll let you okay number
four number four is take
by Sam Smith yeah and number five is
danced with me like Kelly Clarkson I
don't taste animal women of consistence
please talk about Sam Smith permanent
yes
his debut album was like I think one of
them look for me what their and that's
actually a segue entirely the story I'm
so sorry you're right okay go it's a
segue into our next story because
merriam-webster's word of the year for
2019 is they our word of the year for
2019 is they it reflects a surprising
fact even a basic term a personal
pronoun can rise to the top of our data
I guess their word of the year is chosen
based on trends right and I'm just
trying today is it them are they
it's the the word is they although our
lookups are often driven by events in
the news the dictionary is also a prime
resource of her information about
language itself and the shifting use of
day has been subject of increasing study
and commentary in recent years rugs for
they increased by three hundred and
thirteen percent it was twenty nineteen
over the previous year so it's they but
at not the definition of plural but the
definition of someone who is is a binary
turn on fire right suggesting super
super angel I'll still never good over
the year merriam-webster made justice
the year of the word the word of the
year when we were so clearly a part of
that well here's the confusion now
because merriam-webster and dictionary
coms word of the year are becoming to me
like Miss USA and Miss America holy I
forget which one's the thirsty one which
one but know which ones like prestigious
and which ones like trash and not her I
wonder what their word of the I read
they totally have what I'm gonna look it
up 2 percent but dictionary calm we just
reported what was their word of the year
we just reported it yeah it was um uh oh
I know actually excellent up Oh ecstasy
existential well my god for someone with
no memory I remembered something so
reading existential so I guess
merriam-webster is by trend and
dictionary calm is just by like their
editors pick
Urban Decay does not have Urban Decay
urban dictionary and I also can't say
merriam-webster without defined stalkers
device talk or miss Miriam what absurd
I've a lot to talk about with that so
while urban dictionary does not have
the year would you like to know the word
of the day it's a puppy pile a large
pile of people of mixed sexes cuddling
and or heavily petting each other
usually while clothes on but sometimes
without not originally not an orgy
usually done only by people who love
and/or trust each other not always
sexual sometimes just a physical
expression of love or endearment amongst
multiple participants originates from
the carefree innocent love and romping
played that puppies indulge in before
they know better oh it's about puppies
or humans humans but that's where it
originated from it's like I mean if
that's your thing
I'm happy for you know that I am but
that sounds my leg my personal nightmare
ya know like so many people in my bed
like it
want to watch shark tank and go to sleep
a hundred percent okay so here are the
other tent top ten words of the year and
I guess it's based on trends and what
people looked up on merriam-webster hum
number one quid pro quo
number two impeach number three crawdad
I'm not sure what it means uh it's a
kind of animal cute four egregious
five clemency six on my kim kardashian
it's totally responsible for clemency
oh my god yeah also what was word before
that agreed egregious it's because the
pilot on the Boeing flight used the word
in describing the planes the 7/32 seven
bridges and also then you need to
explain yourself egregious is a great
word yeah honestly like kind of how cher
Horowitz wants to start using
sporadically I feel like a Regis is
definitely a word I should start
including like in might or something
yeah it would be honestly egregious if
you didn't ya know else would just look
there's something inherently funny about
the word egregious I can't explain it I
just think it's Regis Philbin numbers a
egregiously number six the number seven
snitty uh
snitty is a good word it's disagreeably
ill-tempered like me at a CVS yourself
check out the total or me know eight
forgiver station never heard of it
you know it was their top look up on
January 24th
it can mean the evasion of
straightforward action or clear-cut
statement Oh someone who's like was she
washing evading I prefer the word of
aiding nine camp oh my god one because
the Met Gala is camp toastin 3 because
counselors snitch I mean honestly I find
like linguistics to be triggering I know
I spoke about this earlier maybe was
last week when we were doing dictionary
word of the day because I took a little
six class in college that really
traumatized me so I'm I'm really over
this story honestly okay but I can't
just use something interesting where
they have the passwords of the year just
to remind everyone yeah
2018 justice 2017 feminism od6
oh my god I thought you meant oh you
said the past words of the year but you
said it fast I think that the passwords
of the year like what people were most
likely to make their passwords passwords
and I thought that was interesting
oh sorry no but what it's been for the
past 10 years 20 2008 was bailout
they're really onto something here oh
yeah Freddie Mac right you've been
watching American greed huh no I just
want to make sure I just remember when
everyone was talking about the economy
and like they were buyouts happening it
was like these banks had like old lady
names like Leslie remember yeah I was
like Fannie Mae I'm like who the [ __ ]
whose mom is that I was so confused like
I just didn't understand like why banks
had real people name like Susan Love
like Merrill Lynch it's like who's
grandma's Merrill
yeah okay fifth and final story even
though it keeps feeling like it's very
very final I hop is opening a new fast
casual chain that has to go pancake
bowls and a DIY pancake bar I mean
honestly I'm done with IHOP like really
look how cute that looks it's called
flicked oki hot incredibly cute name but
ever since they played that stupid prank
on us where we thought that they've
rebranded to iHub International House of
burgers and was like a breakfast
breakfast and there was like a total
prank with Jonathan Cheban like I just
sum over them like I cuz I really
thought that was their name and then it
they never they put so much press into
like with a prank and then not enough
press into letting everyone know that it
was the prank so I think there are a lot
of people out there who'd still think
that they're gonna change our name to
IHOP I agree with you
still think that this is a cute concept
also I think this is very timely for
them because a fast-casual is all the
rage these days and there really isn't
like a great breakfast - casual place
but also I hop isn't what you think of
when you think of like Chipotle Jackie
you hit the nail on the head right there
and then me and Ben have been saying
this for years because I went to Chicago
for the first time like five years
no like eight years ago um to be on The
Steve Harvey Show remember eight years
ago yeah it was wasn't I was still in
college okay but I think it was what
year is it's 2019 it always comes up on
my time hot Oh does it
and they wear that ugly check I think no
but I wasn't in college so it has to
have been five years ago
five years ago Ben came with me and make
sure it wasn't ugly you looked great
okay thank you I was just like I was
just so what's the word that I like I
say was like as if I'm still not I just
like wasn't really that back then so um
me and Ben spent the weekend in Chicago
cuz I could never get on TV and we were
just like celebrating and we went to
this random place for breakfast before
our flight and was called yoke and it
was incredible it was in like a chapel a
because it was still like sit-down diner
but it was like it was just I can't
explain it in any other way and we
thought me it like stumbled upon that's
like hole in the wall when it turns out
it's like a huge like a regional
franchise and Ben loved it so much I
called the owner and tried to get one
opened up in New York and like honestly
there is a gap in the market like I
think if there was a yoke in New York oh
you would love it it's like I'm it's a
diner but it's like it's not all over
the place like it's just breakfast food
yeah and it's really like curated like
I've like frittatas like it's really and
then people would be eating breakfast
food for lunch and for dinner yeah
they're hoping all this food more of
accessible day thing I think I think we
could go for that
I just love yoke I will definitely be
having it when I'm in Chicago next week
take about girls no job comment very few
left oh so just get it yeah just get it
okay let's get it are we ready to recap
honestly yes oh my gosh yesterday was
really thinking about our dear toasters
and coach car
oh what a train pack yeah no I was
feeling for her obviously and I don't
know it's just they really stuck with me
should I see if we got any emails like
with updates or anything cuz like if
some of them might have been old do you
know any mean like yeah let me just
check I don't think that we would have
but they were just sticking with me and
I was thinking about the grandma who
made the comment about yeah the food at
a KD Simmons oh but that's what I was
thinking about - yeah and I was really
thinking I feel strongly that object we
got an update boyfriend with nude
Polaroids oh my god and I'm thinking
about her too when I was like oh my god
I have to burn my apartment I gotta say
I completely forgot I even sent that
email so when you guys read it during
the show yesterday I want to [ __ ] my
pants at work but I'm so honored and
grateful for all of the insight you guys
provided the update he's had after I
destroyed the photo / cards and brought
you the email I didn't tell a soul and
spiraled in my own head for a few days
just trying to act on
round him and shake it off I pretty much
decided that I wasn't gonna say anything
unless he brought it up or gave me a
reason to it's been a few months he
hasn't said anything the box has
remained where I put it which means me
think that indeed guys were just stupid
and they probably didn't realize what he
was all holding on to I eventually told
some friends who also talked me off the
ledge confirming that it was probably
just that case and then then most of
what you guys said yesterday further
cemented that for me so thank you also
thank you for the lols cuz I was dying
when Jackie said that she would burn her
apartment down if this is what happened
to her and when you said maybe he's
sneaking in there at all to whack off to
the pigs after if he wants to living
together I feel like we are more solid
than ever we will probably get married
etc etc so right now I'm feeling good
not being said if I ever see it it's
something with this girl or anyone for
that matter that makes me uncomfortable
or gives me a reason to bring this up I
absolutely come clean about the
situation explain why I bothered me and
get his side of the story but so far it
hasn't come up and honestly hopefully I
don't think that it ever will pick up us
oh my god they're so cute oh my god
she's come to the beacon I'm dead okay
wait they're so cute she's hot
so she Oh super cutie okay Wow I'm so
glad this worked out I'm so glad we
didn't jump to conclusions or that you
didn't jump to conclusions when this
happened and I'm really happy for
everyone involved and also if it ever
when he eventually realizes in years
maybe when you move whatever like you
just like you have to have like a cute
little like nude calendar ready yeah
I've been like I got you Khloe
Kardashian like what she did for Lamar
also if we've ever answered your dear
toasters please write us email updates
we really love it yeah especially like
Coach Carr please I need to know what
happens with train pack I need to know
okay let's jump in real houses in New
Jersey air first so let's talk about it
first they finished their trip in
Jamaica they get home we know that Jo's
appeal gets denied Jennifer does her
roast and I have a lot of thoughts about
it I think first of all she's great at
impressions like and I love that the
editors cut up like what she was
referring to because I never realized
that Margaret says by the way so much
and I thought all of her impressions
were spot-on
they were funny they weren't too mean
except like yeah I thought by the way if
all the things Jackie's ever gotten mad
at like the merriam-webster thing like
was not offensive like I will stand by
that what she said wasn't offensive but
the fact that she wasn't there and she's
doing in front of people who hate her
that's only means I just think she was
being sensitive but so and I'm this high
I don't think so this whole time I've
just lived wouldn't but not liking her
because I think she's like so a suspend
like so sensitive and like feels to need
to like to talk everything through
and now I feel like would be a real time
for have like for her to have a
legitimate gripe and she didn't saying
she couldn't or else she would have been
sensitive Sally right and honestly like
it kind of made me like really like sad
for her because then Dolores like
finally respected her like and it gave
her like a half-assed apology not until
you can joke about your eating disorder
it was just true friend if everyone
really got like surface jokes like
Melissa loves to take selfies she's so
cute cute cute Theresa loves her tight
ass tight I said ass and it's just like
Johnny thank all of those people
actually have other like big things
going on that she clearly ignored she
could have spoken about Joe's
deportation like that would have been I
say him right I thought it was really me
and I was like really like surprised
that she like took it as a good sport
what she really liked she had she didn't
have a choice
she'd never choice like that was said
looks like they beat her down so hard no
it was it was it wasn't cool but I still
don't like Jackie sorry I just like I
just I can't get with her I like her oh
and then what really bothered me was
Melissa and Jackie sitting out cocktails
like talking about how Jennifer is like
so far up Teresa's asked like what she
isn't like making fun everyone's like
Jackie that was literally you last
season like you worked so [ __ ] hard
to become Margaret and Melissa's best
friend like so far up their ass like
making your husband's all be best
friends like it's fine just own it like
don't make fun of Jennifer for doing
exactly what you did she's just like a
little bit less subtle about it yeah no
I didn't think there was any thought
they were being funny and it's like yeah
I'm curious to see if she's gonna roast
those two because she is keen I love
Jennifer I'm keeping them happy I love
Jennifer so brave of her to stand up in
front of her friends like it's hard to
do stand-up anywhere she's funny
unless she's funny I get what she's been
saying this whole time like she really
is a comedian and that's what I love
about this show it's like I feel like
before she went on housewives she was
kind of like just like a subdued almost
like housewife cuz that was like the
role she was playing like mom and I feel
like the show really let her like come
into her own like I feel like she's so
into herself now and like she's getting
to express herself like when would she
have ever done stand-up before this yeah
now she's like the housewife community
when it's clearly depression we don't
have one
we don't have one she needs to go on
tour with the countess yeah I thought it
was a good episode the trip is just like
so
low-budget like there's something about
it that just like really is like so not
house wiping I guess I think the only
thing that was weird to me was like the
two rooms and in despair
any between the two like my couldn't get
to bill is three and three like totally
but every single this looks really fun
honestly but it was also remembered like
when they went um with the dolphins and
then they were like let's just split up
it was so obvious so that like they were
all that was like an acting thing like I
saw a spot at the gym today you want to
go yeah I was like she clearly already
had an appointment yeah honestly I can't
even remember what really happened on
Jersey because I watch Dallas after in
Dallas Dallas took the cake nothing
really happened on Jersey they wrapped
up the trip there was really no fighting
dolores and jennifer jackie like kind of
made peace everyone really did feel that
for jackie which made me feel like happy
that they were all right side of history
and then there was a whole storyline
about Dolores and her situation with the
house and Mike was Haydn David and it's
just so silly like I feel like Dolores
is really contradicting herself because
she keeps saying how content she is like
she's not bothered by the fact that he
works so much she totally understands
and she's really happy in her life yet
she won't move in without a commitment
it's like why right and is she trying to
get married again
I don't know well yes she said she wants
a ring and it's like this is what we
always say like someone like Dolores
does not need to be getting married
again like she's so happy in her life
she's making a lot of her own money now
from the show like being independent
woman you have a partner but I guess
it's like if she moves in with him and
they could just break up and when you
don't have like anything legal bounding
you together it makes it really easy to
then you're always she's on edge like am
I gonna be kicked out his house soon
right but then it's like if she gets
kicked out she just goes back to living
with Frank I love Frank I mean they're
the threat all that we need know and
like Frank being like a full-time cast
member but he's actually not even
married to anyone is so funny
no and him like starting stuff like
telling David what Dolores said next
week he's like cheering and starting
things photo and I'm all about it no
he's so funny he's a cutie and he
birthed the other Frank Catania so like
we're grateful we are grateful and thank
you too
now zones tuxedos yes of course always I
mean let's jump in to real houses of
Dallas where we wrapped up our trip in
Thailand so much happened we ended we
picked up the episode where we left off
which was like though weird temper
tantrum lutely and was throwing when
they got back from the ping pong show
and you know what was so weird they went
straight to the next morning when they
had a footage from the night before
remember of yeah so I don't know why
they just didn't go chronologically
because it seemed like a lot happened
that we didn't know about because you
thought everyone just went to bed but no
Cameron in Carey and Brandi went to the
roof got drinks like first of all I'm
just loving Carey she seems like such a
good time they were getting drinks and
and Cameron told them to come to her
room where she was hysterically crying
because Leanne tried to make her feel
bad that people aren't oust are gonna be
talking about her for going to the
red-light district and like giving her
such a pit for absolutely no reason for
absolutely no reason
and that's what she said to Deandra when
she was being friends with Brandi and
also that's what she said to Stephanie I
love that they they clipped back to that
because I totally forgot that this is
like a trend that LeAnn does she makes
people feel bad that their reputation is
gonna be taken down for doing certain
things or being friends of certain
people's is such a weird black character
trait no it's such a weird thing to say
and I'm glad that she was called out for
it and especially like for Cameron who I
think a righty is just so like nervous
about being on the show and and she said
when she came on this show that it's not
well received advice and like so
everything that she does I'm sure is
under a microscope so like to go from a
high Cameron was having the best time in
Thailand like drinking making new
friends and to go from that high to like
oh my god I just ruined my life world
hangover
Cameron like she married into this and
it's like I did this to my husband's
family like oh my god I had such a pit
for her to and I just want to say and I
say it every week I'm in love with
Cameron me too
and even even though she was really
disappointing me at the it was a
disappointment I understand why to
everyone else it was because they
thought finally she was gonna turn but
for Cameron this is the first time her
best friend Leanne has done something to
wrong her and one you don't just end a
friendship over one thing they do not
end a friendship but in order have a
healthy friendship with someone you have
to be open with them she was open and
then - at the table when everyone is
sitting there gang talking about and
ganging up on your friend and it's
something that you already kind of
buried you're not gonna join the pylon
you're just not like that's her closest
friend at the table why would she be
with these like I agree with what all
the other women were saying because
they've seen this so many times but for
Cameron one instance isn't just gonna
make her flip because she's a loyal
friend no totally but so even if she's
gonna end her friendship with Leon it's
not gonna be in front of all these women
who she knows like cuz she still cares
about the end and to me it just made
Cameron even more relatable and like the
fact it just shows that she has a she
considered lianna real friend know
because even one-on-one with Leon she
wasn't being upfront like when she goes
back to the room and first of all Leon
slams the door on her face and leaves
hammering out there like a little doggie
like that was one of the saddest things
ever by the way that's number two
nope no but even after that now they're
alone one on one like she can't even be
up front somehow Leigh Ann sitting on
the floor crying and Cameron's hugging
her like because I think she's just like
humble
herself and it's like I understand that
I'm upset I'm upset but so is Liane she
was just trying to be a good friend I
just I'm just getting really like fed up
because it's like a friendship it's it's
supposed to be like an equal partnership
and it's not equal yeah this to me is
like reminding me like with LVP and the
magazine's is Kyle and like Kyle almost
turned but she didn't like it's a and
but eventually she does because it
builds right and we're still at magazine
Stage one
we're so ya know for sure for sure um I
just after and I didn't want them to end
their friendship but it's like someone's
your friend like you have to tell them
what they did wasn't okay and she felt
that she did okay I know I just like saw
it from her perspective where it's like
yes I'm hurt but also this person is my
friend and I'm not gonna like dig in on
their pain right now but in other side
interview she was being way more direct
but I almost feel like something else
had to happen great because things are
very different now and I want to talk
about the elephant in the room which is
the the Mexican thing oh my god this in
this episode I thought last episode was
like the worst didn't baby that was
worth it could be in this episode it is
atrocious it's so much worse and I get
why camera and she was like I'm
obviously not gonna stand here right now
and tell Carrie what Leanna's would say
no matter because it's gonna ruin the
trip but it's like we were in the trip
more ruin the trip more and it's like
but Liam has been saying the stuff since
their first trip to Mexico like she's
been saying like alluding to it and I
just don't know why no one has brought
it up yet and we've seen the preview for
next week that it's the season finale
which I feel like happened really fast
um that it gets brought up and it's like
the whole topic of conversation at burns
party but it's almost like why wasn't
this brought up sooner like Carrie and
Liana have had such a treacherous
friendship and it's there's like a huge
elephant in the room as to why they
can't get along and it's like obviously
because Liam feels a certain type of way
about Carrie and no one's telling Carrie
like what that is why did Liane say in
Mexico about her she said she said it in
her confessional not in x-ray like you
they film those confessionals
the week of they film every week yeah so
I guess for the other women Thailand was
the first time they were hearing it yeah
Cameron the minute she got home and had
one
in the car with Carrie when they're
going to the final party she tells her
so I think I hope Carrie you like
doesn't get hurt it's like such a mean
thing to say oh my god it's awful it's
it's really like it was so like imagine
of someone like you weren't getting
along with you found out they were just
like behind your back being like that
[ __ ] Jew what you're writing Jim oh
my god I would die like I would cry in
my car like it's really really upsetting
so I like want her to find out obviously
but like it's so hurtful that I don't
even know and I really um I need to know
like what sort of consequences are gonna
be taken because this is like a level of
like pettiness that hasn't ever really
been breached on Housewives like people
say the most horrible things to each
other like you threw your mother down
the stairs but they never go like racist
and it's unprecedented and I kind of
hope that like whatever action is taken
it's like ruled with an iron fist like
it's really not okay well someone
commented earlier in the stream that I'm
watching up inside which I didn't watch
Brant what Andy said like made it seem
like LeAnn will be getting tired oh my
god Deandra this who was on last night
Deandra no jamie-lynn Sigler and Delores
Delores yes oh okay well I didn't see it
though so I just saw a comment that said
that I agree that it has to be taken
seriously addressing it at the Reunion
and having LeAnn apologize she said it
in her now in candidly and in her
confessionals and it's it's so
unacceptable yeah it's kind of like how
there there really is a line in
housewives and it's like Phaedra crossed
that line when she did that thing about
saying candy like drugged people and had
sex of them and like that's why she got
fired like and I as much as I love
Phaedra like I do think that was the
right thing to do like you can't you
can't take it that far and to me this is
the same it's much worse honestly so I
as if something has to be done yeah it's
really it's really not okay and I'm
really curious to see how they handle it
like when because everything is so
delayed like now people are seeing it
now people are talking about it on
social media have they film the reunion
yet yes yes then we found like justice
you know like Nicole Kidman
I need to see like where we're at you
know yeah I totally agree next then the
season finale looks so good I think I
can and I called you because I was so
shook because I actually to rewind
because I couldn't recognize whose voice
is what it was because they got someone
saying something on mic
that he wasn't filming so I was like
who's voice is that it sounded so
unfamiliar I rewind it and it was court
Westcott Cameron's husband being like
you ought to stay away from her with
that racist [ __ ] like telling Cameron
like you can be on the show like to have
around like you cannot be friends with
someone who said that like that's not
okay so I like that he's guiding her
towards the work towards life
so I'm so looking forward to next week
also did you see that Bravo next week is
doing um OC 2 nights like the finale on
Tuesday and the reunion on Wednesday I
think they're having problems with
ratings on OC so they're trying to like
either change things to like jump start
some ratings or get the season to end
faster perhaps but I kind of like that
because I watched week to week so that
we can talk about on this show but I it
would be so these two seasons would be
so much better if I could just binge
watch them I mean everything Netflix has
ruined like what we tweak television for
me I love watching things in bulk I
would love to watch housewives like
binge it but we can't because we talked
about it on the show so I think that's
actually cool I like that yeah me too or
maybe like they don't want to go into
Christmas you know like with the weeks
yes me because like you don't want to
wait for a reunion right and it's like
if you do two in one week they'll end
right before New Year's as opposed to
after New Year's where it's like the
years over like yeah and Vanderpump
rules is premiering right Tuesday so OC
might be like done by them whatever um
so interesting I just like cam is
everything to me this season she was
hoping Brandi and Stephanie were just
like the most logical people on this
entire trip yeah and I totally get why
Brandi got up from the table like first
of all that dinner was just a [ __ ] show
Archer and I get it it's like Brandi has
been like she she's like of all them
that can put up with Leeanne the least
and Liana has been solely in this scene
this trip and brandi is just like stood
and and taken it but like eventually she
just hit a wall and I totally get it
even though the conversation had nothing
to do with her like sometimes you just
can't be in the presence of someone so
unreasonable no no I totally understood
that was the craziest dinner ever no
total Andy ang was just like living for
the reckoning of Rishi and DeAndre
doesn't know how to how to be a human
being like she just she has no like
social conduct and she just like piles
on and it's like D'Andra you're in the
right here just like sit down yeah it
just takes away take the win let it
happen and
she was like exactly like and then
Leanne was like okay you don't have to
like like just Andhra like sometimes
just like shut the [ __ ] up ya know um
you know it was really bothering me was
that they all got those purses which are
really cute and when Deandra Cameron
came to Deandra and carries room
Cameron was wearing like an orange pink
dress and a brown bag and then Carrie
had an orange purse Carrie had an orange
person and a nude outfit like they
should have switched bags it was
bothering me so yeah this bags are
really cute yeah oh they were so cute
mom and they like something there's just
so cute you know Carrie talking about
how she negotiates everything when she
came to America so funny
but that's so true like it's definitely
a cultural thing like an Israel like
you're supposed to negotiate like I'm
never supposed to just like pay what
people tell you they just like it in
like a restaurant like it easy to think
about cuz that's not a thing no no it's
so the price is the price
I like Carrie a lot like I hope she
stays yeah and I was reading Twitter
which I don't know why and people were
saying like the cast is gonna be so
shaken up next season like we're just
like Carrie's going no I think carries I
think everyone's gonna say except maybe
land I think that they have to get rid
of it's just so weird it's like I
understand like if you feel a certain
way about someone but you on TV like you
know you shouldn't say like one time it
slips but like literally four times I
mean she thinks it's an okay thing to
say she doesn't realize that it's wrong
which is even worse yeah it's really
crazy times over there in Dallas yeah
but it's such a it's actually really
turned around I was like in a little
trepidatious at the beginning of a
season not sure where you know we were
gonna go but I think it's been such a
great season I think this trip to
Thailand was a really important trip and
I think all the women like are really
bucketeer standards in terms of um oh my
god yes it was so looks like do you hear
and you see the difference in Jamaica
vs. Thailand
like not only the destination but like
the level of hotel like they looked at
they were at like an all-inclusive
resort like me and my friends would know
and everyone was like an apprentice that
intial suite not just psycho one men oh
yeah you know everyone had just as nice
I mean Brandi and Stephanie suite was so
nice and I was so cute like try to stay
there were them for a night like I love
Travis the love and to me it's like New
Jersey is more of a franchise than
Dallas is like Jeff Dallas got canceled
like I wouldn't be surprised I would be
sad obviously but it's like it's still
new so for them to have gotten such a
luck strip and the
housewives who have been around for 15
season like going to slumming it in
Jamaica like I don't think Teresa can go
very far
oh because of her kids and her situation
like she I don't think she can be on a
completely other times only like they
had to go to a different Beach to go to
the beach like you know what I mean it's
been a weird trip why can't they just go
to the Bahamas though like that when the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills when
SLS Baha Mar oh no they went to rosewood
Baha Mar yeah I loved that hotel and we
had such a great time there are about
try party
I had such fun memories of Baha Mar like
um just like the people on your Rattrap
party like it was just the cleaning
times yeah like the bachelor parties are
hard like mixing camp school/college
home friends and it was just such a good
time it was such a good time I mean it
should go back yeah go straight time any
time I will go Gianna Gianna panty girls
night
no GTO girl stripout yeah just GT girls
trip
okay thank you guys so much for watching
the morning testimony a morning show if
you want to get our shirts these are
available at chop morning toast calm
I believe the black is still available
yes black is still available white is
still available the white is the new
color but both are available now at shop
morning totes are calm so make sure to
snag one up honestly it's the easiest
thing to wear where you just want to be
like cute you can go to sleep you can
hit the clubs just depends how much
easier and you didn't definitely hit the
clubs you can throw on a headband and
just change the whole game thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcast can be found since
iTunes Spotify CHR Public Radio
iHeartRadio cash box all the places so
wherever you watch listen give a five
star review talk about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much we'll see you tomorrow on
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
you